hello everyone this is Amir here from Audio
Science Review welcome to the debunking
channel which seems to do what i have to do every
other day as far as videos giving your requests
so uh today we're going to talk about the
usb cables do they make an audible difference
do they make a measurable difference let's
find out i think there'll be a message for
for everyone no matter which camp you're
in first i want to actually talk to our
the objectivist camp and the notion that the
usb is a digital transmission cable therefore
it can't possibly make a difference in the
output of an audio device attack USB deck
back in 2017 i ran a set of tests with my old
audio precision analyzer so the display looks
a little different than my newer one and what
i did was that i took a Schiit modi 2 deck and
you'll see me use this stack often in my videos
when i want to show sensitivity to jitter and
noise the stack is a much older deck than the
state-of-the-art ones that shed sells today and
uh it's powered over usb and uh it it's fairly
sensitive to nature of usb so i can even plug
it into one usb port on one machine and then
another machine and have the results vary so
you know uh when i try to show sort of the worst
case susceptibility for noise over usb uh i always
use the shed mode too and what i did was that i
tested it with the Sonore microRendu which is a
streamer so the streamer was a sort of appliance
streamer running linux and uh i used a long
uh you know cheap crappy thin USB
cable it was a 28 gauge cable and
it was six foot and then i compared it to a six
inch generic cable so both of these are generic
cables just different lengths and as you see in
here there's quite a bit of measured difference
in here this is our 12 kilohertz tone that you
often see in my jitter test and the longer cable
produced more of these spikes jitter or noise or
whatever they are in this stack so absolutely we
can measure the difference between two usb cables
anybody who says that our instrumentation isn't
good enough to measure such differences is wrong
um we can and i'm showing you right now that we
have indeed measured um at the time i also had
this fancy audiophile usb cable um some random
brand uh from triad wire labs called the uar link
um and it's a pretty short cable and uh i compared
that uh to the short generic cable it actually uh
was worse performance so just because something's
audio file cable obviously doesn't mean that it's
been tested properly and measured properly so in
this case with this sensitive dac um the one in
red is our fancier audiophile cable even though
it's short it still produced uh it produced worse
performance nothing much but but it was measurable
and then i finally had this little stub usb cable
which is just you know goes from one to the other
with no length between the two uh it's rigid
and we see that the rigid one is actually better
than the uh even the short generic cable that i
had before so uh length is your friend in here um
the longer the length is the more ground loops
you create between the devices on your computer
and that those can bleed into the deck um
and cause interference and cause noise so
be careful in saying digital's digital bits are
bits in these arguments because that argument does
not hold because usb is carrying data we are able
to extract data reliably in these short lengths
but it's also got power and ground
and the power and ground is used
in the dac and if a dac doesn't properly
filter that five volt before he uses it
and or it's not designed well and it can get
into ground loops with the computer which
happens to always have a noisy ground you can
impact measurable analog output of the dac so
everything i've showed you is what comes out of a
dac i'm not showing you what's on the wire i don't
care what's on the wire i care about whether my
end audio product is distorted or not distorted
we're absolutely able to measure with our
instrumentation differences between these cables
and turns out the champion is the shortest one the
shortest one has the least amount of voltage drop
and least amount of impedance between it the
ground for the deck and the ground for the pc so
it tends to help with that with a deck like
a shed modi too um i'll skip over these uh
but this is an important chart i was lying to you
with those graphs you know that if you go back to
all of these scales what do you see minus 144
to minus 120 so this is still uh you know below
threshold overhearing so i've zoomed way in and
then magnified all those variations if i don't
magnify him and i look at the best case in the
worst case this is the difference that you see
not zeros on top minus 140s at the bottom and
look at the difference we're talking between
minus 140 and minus 135 or minus 130. so no
case can be made of audible difference here
i'm just showing that we have very sensitive
instrumentation and the bits are not bits because
we're dealing with analog nature of the voltage
and power supply coming from a computer or feeding
into a dac and if you have a dac that's sensitive
this way you want to be careful about this okay
actually yeah i can show you this one this is
on a Behringer UMC204hd very cheap DAC and audio
interface and it actually showed no difference
even though it's a cheap low-cost dac it actually
you know you couldn't see the difference so
it took that Schiit modi there's one specific
sort of unicorn of a dac that is so sensitive
to these things that i happen to know about
and i exaggerated difference if i just step
up to another budget deck which is this one
you see no difference and indeed if i
use chess current products or any other
half decent dac today you won't be able to make
show repeatable difference like this but just
know that extra at the extreme the argument is
right that the cables can make a difference as
with all things tweaks in high end there's always
some element of truth to them of course they don't
bother to measure or even know it themselves so
it takes me to go analyze it and say here's a
bone you could have put this on your website
and show some difference um so anyway so
remember don't say bits or bits what you want
to say is that you want to have a competent dac
which costs almost nothing to design doesn't
care about these vagaries of usb and at any rate
anything that's half fancy will also have its own
power supply so for high-end users to go buy these
cables makes no sense what do they think that
their usb interface in their fancy deck was
poorly designed and they needed a better cable
they couldn't do anything internally to fix that
problem sort of strength imagination but anyway
fast forward two years later this is 2020 a year
ago i was given a cable from a popular company
kimber cable has a stupid name of b bus usb
yeah it is a b bus but come up with a better name
if you're gonna charge me uh sixty dollars now
sixty dollars there's nothing for a high-end cable
this is like to a high-end user this would be dirt
this wouldn't even be acceptable usb cables go up
to 20 000 now depending on length or even more and
i'm not kidding you i don't want to tell you the
branding given promotion but there are companies
that make 17 to 20 000 usb cable and i know
people have bought them and claimed that it was
night and day you plugged it in and all kinds of
magical things happen um this cable is kind of a i
think it's an ugly looking cable it doesn't look
high-end at all it looks like a same old cheap
cable you buy for 10 bucks and it's got a couple
of ferrite cores on it but otherwise doesn't
feel like a 60 dollar item to me he says you
will be shocked when you hear what these kimber
cables can do to your music for your music wow
but it doesn't say what kind of shock maybe
it's electrical shotgun i don't know but if i'm
paying 10 times for a cable i hope so i hope i get
something that's shockingly better um they have
an endorsement from Chris Conaker here who runs
the an audio site that used to be called computer
audiophile but now it's called the audiophilestle
and it's a it's an online call review site i don't
know how much reviewing he does but it's a forum
and discussion and folks hang out there um he
says he's been a customer forever um and he had
high expectations for this usb cable and as soon
as he plugged it in here's the original recording
i guess with any other cable he was hearing
something else with that something else is i
don't know says i can't recommend it enough it's
very inexpensive for high-end quality it is as i
explained for fifty dollars such an improvement
is no brainer so there's some improvement
um quit listening to interference uh really i
you know i listen to usb cables all day long
uh i don't hear interference i don't measure
interference uh somehow he was hearing
interference before and uh trust me on this one
pick up this cable and if it does what it does
to his system well he says he'll do the same thing
to your system wow we're supposed to trust folks
i wish it was so easy i wish i could just tell
you trust me don't waste money on this cable but
my style is when i give you information when
i give you opinion i'd like to be able to back
that opinion with something trust me what does
that mean why should i trust you what are your
qualifications in hearing interference in usb
cable uh let's demonstrate that let's see you
prove that your ears are that great anyway i'll
go ahead and and test this using my modern audio
precision analyzer i'll plug in a modern dac
state-of-the-art DAC but hey still a cheap
DAC because i think Topping for 500. i forget so
not high-end by anybody's high-end standard but
you know high-end by our standards we plug in with
Kimber kimber cable spelled funny and we see the
superlative performance of of this dac distortion
is below 130 db noise floors almost fallen off the
bottom of my chart um it puts out 4 volts as
we ask it 4.05 8 volts coming out distortion
plus noise is .0094 percent so you got two more
zeros to it as a ratio we convert that to sign
at uh we get 120 121 db so at least five to
be better than threshold of hearing and uh
it's even better than that i'm not going to
get into psychoacoustics right now so this is
exceptional performance so i then switch that
out and use what i use um just which is this
amazon basics usb cable it's very supple which is
what i like i do a lot of removing and plugging
things in and everything i need i like to have my
cable feel good and it's got nice connectors on
it and i really like it i don't like some of the
other varieties they have i like this usb b cable
i've gotten their other usb micro usb
and i didn't like that but for regular
amazon basic doesn't get more generic than this
right i'm sure amazon didn't do any audio surveys
with that so i plugged that in and look at the
distortion again all these zeros nine four what
was it before all those zeros nine four even this
right hand digit did not change i mean imagine if
i just blow on that machine probably making up
a change to digit the change but did not change
with that uh uh with this swapping cable look at
the output voltage 4.058 volts before 4.05 8 volts
before one millivolts accurate frequency that are
on accurate that are on accurate gosh i mean where
do you hang your head on you look at the spectrum
displays identical noise interference distortion
all of that is encapsulated in this measurement
uh the full transfer function of the device
not a thing has changed uh a bugaboo is jitter
people think oh there's noise over usb that noise
goes into a dac and creates jitter noise can cause
jitter so don't say that can't happen if you don't
clean up that five volt and you take it and feed
it as a reference to a to a dac it can actually
cause modulation of the output and it will
create symmetrical tones that you'll see
around the main tone we actually do have uh some
jitter in this product uh we can see them but
guess what amazon basics cable or kimber cable
identical they're landing on top of each other
you just can't separate them i mean this is
a stress test designed to bring out jitter
if it exists it's high frequency tone which
exaggerates jitter the higher the frequency the
more jitter same amount of gibber the hardest
amplitude is it's proportional to frequency
and uh we still see no difference whatsoever in
this little tick here whatever this is right here
that was also reproduced i mean this nothing
has been removed with this other cable
and as it should be this is a you when you buy
a proper desktop deck that i recommend to you
it does all this stuff they know usb is not
clean i mean it takes two seconds to put a
scope on a usb cable finite lane well you
don't use that voltage as is you bring it in
they have dc to dc converters that convert that
to other or in this case may not even use the
five volt off of a usb anyway and isolation
is provided between the usb interface
and the sensitive dac so that the noise
that arrives over usb cable doesn't jump
and pollute the output of that that can happen
that's what i showed you with the shed mode e2
here it doesn't happen i can take a 99 back and
show you the identical result so don't fall for
this so i have some explanation in here but
i've already talked to you about that um that
you know you can get noise if you have really
really poor dac but even then i can't make a
case of audibility uh until you break the device
where the packets are falling on the floor and
in that case it's great static actually it's not
that the sound state changes veils removed things
are more analog like all of that when people
sense those things it's just manufactured by the
this creative mind the mind loves to make up
things i mean we have so many neurons in there
and we'd love to uh think we're also right about
all these things it's just the human nature where
we're self-confident and that keeps us from
being always depressed thinking we're gonna die
and so we manufacture uh improvements in sound
readily with our brain and when we plug in a
new cable uh we say wow look at this i paid more
attention it sounds better and then you take it
out and you program yourself thinking that the old
cable must not sound as good and indeed it won't
so there is some element of truth
in there between usb cables but
as soon as you go you know in anything decent
these days it just simply is not material
all these high performance measurements that you
see that i show you i use that amazon basics cable
where i'm showing you measurements down to 160 db
how am i able to keep the noise so low how am i
keeping the interference from the analyzer my
the source i use by the way this is not some
fancy source this is my everyday workstation
that's running right now my streaming app
my audio precision analyzer has a CPU pig
app that runs that sucks one core drive
and there's activity running this is my
everyday machine i may have email running
all the stuff's running photoshop running and
yet it's feeding data to uh on a generic amazon
basis cable to attack and attacks analog
output the final thing that we hear is
being captured and analyzed to incredible
precision and yet we don't see any flaws
i mean these things couldn't be more accurate i
mean look at these values and tell me how could
this this cable make a difference it absolutely
cannot why did chris think there was a difference
just pure imagination he just needs to learn how
to do a control test a control test simply says
look let's just use your ears and only
your ears not your eyes not your brain
knowledge of what you're plugging into who the
manufacturer is that's just your ears we trust
your ears actually people say we don't trust
the ears we trust measurements no no i love
i trust ears but i only want to hear that what
goes in your ear not what else you synthesize
that oh you've forever been a kimber customer you
think their cables are great so of course if you
forever think that and you plug in their usb
cable and it feels and looks nicer he said wow
it it made a difference yeah your brain will
manufacture that it will it will definitely
think that the problems that that effect wears
off because it's not real it's manufactured it
wears off have a loved one i've said this 20
times swap cables on you when you don't know
do it listen for a whole day listen for a whole
week do this for as long as you need to do there's
no hurry we're not watching every day just
keep a log was it kimber cable was it amazon
basic was it kimber cable was it amazon base have
somebody else switch them and then hide them with
a towel or something where you can't see the cable
simple test somebody that believes in the stuff
should do this bring your log first just show
us text we don't even need any video proof
for now just do this simple test ten times you
ran this you waited one day one hour six weeks
whatever long you want there's no restriction
on time we're not there to make you nervous
we're not there to make you uh stressed out if the
results don't come out the way you think you don't
want to have to tell us you could just chuckle so
there shouldn't be any stress in this blind test
you know but if you have if you can prove 10 out
of 10 times or 9 or 10 times you can tell which
cable is plugged in you'll be a hero you you will
have changed the laws of physics when it comes to
audio you you know if you just demonstrate that if
you can do it quickly in a few minutes fantastic
leave a camera running and have somebody else
administer this test that's single blind that's
fine doesn't have to be double-blind as long as
that other person doesn't wink at you and tell you
what that what cable's in there is as good as
double blind we're not you know masochists when
it comes to this but give us something other than
trust me trust me this cable is great go ahead
and cough up 50 60 on a cable why i don't you
know give me some something to go by we're not
lemmings we're not stupid give us something these
are measurements why is the manufacturer showing
any measurements what is manufacturers saying they
improved why are those improvements not measurable
if they've changed how do they know they're
building the right thing if they don't measure
do they not test these things in a factory how
are they testing what are they testing for what
if their chemistry is wrong that day and they're
building a different kind of cable they don't run
now so it's important to measure it's important
to prove your point have some backup has some
reason that your opinion should be valid anyway i
won't bore you anymore with my lectures hopefully
you learned something about measure USB cables
and evaluated see you in the next video bye bye